[Music]
one of the reasons you wanted to stop by
which is very cool is NBA 2k13 yes this
is a terrific video Ganesh sewing
basketball video game of all time that's
actually a fact I didn't make that up
I'm the sexiest man in America that's
something I made up we you you you love
this video game obviously and people say
this is the best game I just heard you
say it we have you brought a clip here
to demonstrate how great the action is
and you customize this a little bit did
you know and you can add people and they
actually look like themselves so mm-hm
you'll see okay let's see who you added
that's I think we know what's gonna
happen let's take a look
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hi well first of all was a nice play I
gave you the alley-oop so you and I are
incredibly insane right my biggest
complaint is what I do the weird what am
i doing after I score can we see that
again what's going on there with my face
after I score III that's fine that's
enough that's enough
I don't do that okay maybe I do
you know what I will say about this game
I've played it and the game does very
accurately depict my basketball skills
perfectly accurate let's take a look
[Applause]
how did you switch to you so fast he
gets regenerated did this after the
alley-oop they traded me we can't have
that you know you are a very intense
player and which is a great thing much
is discussed about what's called the
Blake face this is not the dunking face
this is a face that you give teammates
when you want the ball you let them know
it's that you want the ball and it is an
intense its expression I've heard it's
intense it's not only when I want the
ball its is pretty much throughout the
whole game but I didn't even realize I
did it until one of my teammates kids
started impersonating me yeah Chris
Chris Chris Paul's son did an impression
of you giving the Blake face and it was
a great moment
it's actually very realistic it's
effective though it gets the job done
let me ask you a quick question you get
fouled a lot obviously you're a big
threat to the other team
you get hacked more than just about any
other player and constantly being sent
to the foul line do you
does it change or do you think you
should change the way you play is there
anything you can do about that because
they are all over you know it happens
you know it's a part of the game I wish
it would happen a little less so not as
hard sometimes but it's you know it's
one of those things I just got a you got
to play through you got to understand
why it's happening and deal with it
right but you've never thought like have
other players ever given you advice
about yes say here's a way to maybe make
sure that people hack you a little less
Cobie gave me some advice I don't think
I can really say the real advice but
basically told me to punch everybody I
mean if someone fouls you get up and
punch them you just fight you said fight
somebody one time it'll all stop
happening so but then you'd get in a lot
of trouble wouldn't you cuz this isn't
hockey it wasn't great advice some
advice just start punching people in the
face